okay so uh megan fox put her
estranged ex-husband on blast because
ever since she started dating machine
gun kelly she's been
very uh public about their relationship
and there was a photo that she posted
with
him and then the caption was something
along the lines of
my beautiful boy or like achingly
beautiful some
something like that and a couple hours
later her ex-husband posted a photo of
all of their sons
saying the exact same thing kind of
being shady and ever since then
it's been very apparent that he would
try yeah he's jealous he's kind of like
uh throwing shade her way and machine
gun kelly's way
he posted this photo originally with the
caption of like uh
happy halloween with his son and
megan fox wrote this paragraph out
basically saying like why did you have
to post this photo
with our son making it seem like i'm an
absent mom like i'm spending all this
time with my boyfriend
i had him the other day that's her only
yeah
hers yeah oh okay can't post a picture
of halloween with his kids or being like
i think he's making me look like
absentee mothers like i think it's all
the stuff that he's done before this
that's why it's like one of those things
because he's
like subliminally kind of like taking
shots at her making it seem like she's
spending all this time
with mgk and not with their kids while
he's like staying at home
why don't they just call each other i
want to do this yeah i do this on social
media i see homeboy
all the time in calabasas where i eat
that he's there all the time
and uh he was there when i was there i
was getting coffee and his with a
baddie a straight back it was i like
that i like to hear stuff like that
i mean yeah i think they should just
call each other man all right
i think it's tough i like machine gun
music
i'm a fan of machine gun kelly but he's
a little bit of a [ __ ]
up like if i'm if i'm brian austin green
and like i got kids
and then there's a video was it two
weeks ago him drunk kicking out a window
in a car
what are you doing this is the this is
the route you're going
like you know how this ends that guy is
a [ __ ]
he needs therapy so [ __ ] bad that
dude
so bad yeah howard turned i was like man
you probably should see it there but
he's like nah i don't need that man
and howard turns like i'm telling you
you do that
however the tower is like freaky when
people say nah i don't need that i'm
like
because howard howard stern was like
dude i've like i swear by therapy now
like i need it so bad
yeah he's like i used to just lash out
at people and it's like that's what
machine gun kelly's doing
but if i have kids you don't want
machine gun kelly as the step dad
around your kids yeah the name kicking
out [ __ ] windows of cars and [ __ ]
machine gun i mean but he's got a kid of
his own yeah but you know he's like
i don't mean he's a good dad how do you
know
that is let me tell you something dude
with the glasses it's kind of yeah right
glasses oh you take the glasses off let
me drop my eyes
rub your eyes go ahead bruh he's about
to have an idea in his album though
in his album he's so high and his
daughter's on the album there's like an
interlude part you know she's good uh
she knows they're talking about
conversation and she's like dad do you
remember it like when i was a kid or
anything we did because you were so
high or drunk all the time do you
remember any of that and she leaking out
and he's like yeah i remember some of it
he was like
[ __ ] dude oh really his name's machine
gun kelly
that's his rap name come on dog have you
ever shot a machine gun
who knows we should shut up we shot that
automatic gun
in texas that was
that's besides the point but were you
gonna say i mean
all right i mean i don't know the guy i
don't either i'm just not gonna
judge him i'm not either but i've got to
be bad on it yeah
if he had to bet on it i know yeah i
mean look a little look a little uzi his
name is a little uzi vert and he's not
like
i mean he's soft that dude is so dark
damn bro
so gunner so so good names is like yo
it's like
insecurity you trying to first of all
machine gun kelly that's not original
right the machine
no no kelly used to be a gang a mafia
guy in chicago
so that's not original okay so he
already played jurassic continue
i'm just saying i don't think he's gonna
win father yet
that's not you what about pistol pete
maverick who what's that
pistol p maverick the nba player old
school nba oh school yeah yeah he's a
great uh
jazz yeah lsu oh
went to pasadena pasadena
he went to lsu with the college he
played
pistol pete so i'm saying that's
shooting basketball bro what about 40
glock
but but he goes by machine gun kelly
because he can rap fast
that's why he goes by that mm-hmm he can
rap but now but now it's less wrapping
more
pop like more the more punk yeah
i like i like machine gun kelly i've
heard awful stories about him offset
awful stories but i still [ __ ] with
them because travis barker's my boy and
try someone
yeah travis is literally one of the best
people on earth
and he [ __ ] him so i gotta imagine
machine gun kelly is a good person
thanks for that follow travis
he's great yeah that's my god not real
let me know if you want to jam
okay copy that with the best drummer
alive right now you want to jam
well wouldn't i that would be awesome
why not was last time you jammed
uh like a full-on band yeah oh that's
been a minute probably
uh 2000 remember when i did it on stage
um yeah just give me how many years ago
i think it was like two years ago yes
that's a long time he plays every day
man kiss my ass doesn't mean i don't
know how to jam with a band you can play
music you play music play music
you are you can go you can go go into a
gym right now and get some ufc [ __ ]
going down
no you couldn't get a pop and you could
the basics
of just rolling around i wouldn't be i
wouldn't be like hey jon jones let's
[ __ ] when i'm in town let's spar
you wouldn't you wouldn't no god no i
know my [ __ ] he's not your weight class
he's not your weight glass though
he's my weight he's like hey bro john's
a heavyweight
what you think everywhere he's my
heavyweight but you're a thick
heavyweight yeah that's true
is that a division yeah it gotta be
john's probably 240 right now i didn't
expect you to roll around with someone
that's heavyweights though doug is it oh
265. oh wow the point that's such a big
gap that's a big
the point is he's the best drummer on
earth and i get that now
you haven't played in quite some time
and you're trying to jam
i've been playing in quite some time
that's different if you're playing your
guitar constantly you're fine i don't
know i don't you know what i don't know
bands
exactly i know i tried to use the ufc
i love the bear yeah that was bad i
thought you were gonna go to the
comedian route i was about to say put in
comments i don't know where you're
trying to go
yeah like yeah if you hit some yeah a
community of like your favorite comedian
you're like hey let's do
a show together yeah yeah but i'm a
practicing comedian i have
six shows this weekend i constantly do
stand up
now if i took four years off i'm like
hey bill burr first can i
jump on your show he'd like no
problem you know what i'm saying chan
like if you're playing guitar constantly
yeah and then when you're rolling with
someone that's got drunk
you're really in that [ __ ] hey when i
played with that band i didn't know
those guys you killed it i just started
playing
two years again two years ago dude but
how many months would you
did you play before you started jamming
with those guys two years ago which guys
the guys that she was yeah did you build
up too much oh no actually no
a couple months ago was when the last
time i jammed with a band you're making
this up no i'm not i just can you record
something
yeah well yeah bunch of songs he's got
an album coming out
oh for cats no no for something else it
was me
my me my homies we wanted to do some
punk covers yeah and we we recorded it
in this studio hey fun fact shout out to
the same show are those guys
professionals yeah they play with kill
tony
oh the comedy band yeah let's just leave
that right there yeah hey bro
let's just do that i'm talking about
traffic i'm talking about
travis [ __ ] [ __ ] barking i
mean
no but travis cry away from travis back
and i get that i get that i'm saying
like i don't think it's weird that
okay prince wanted to jam with dave
grohl
and prince can play every instrument
instrument yeah so what does he need to
jam with anyone for he can play every
instrument and really good
if dave grohl's a professional musician
you're not going to win you know i'm not
going to explain my witnesses i don't
mean
i know me because i know you're
interested you know i know my truth i
know what it is let me see
play more man i'm sure traffic's like
yeah i'll play with you just play more
well he just shouted them out so i'm
pretty sure they you know we'll see what
happens
i would love that yeah it'd be fun would
you do something if they were
if i wish i could play an instrument are
you gonna play anything no i wish
not even like what about the school i
don't know i can't play the drums i play
what
the uh what's that thing in school it
was called a recorder yeah
they dip it and they're dipping in scope
i remember i'd always put my lips on be
all sweet
by the time i was in school you had to
have your own because they didn't want
to do that no they they had them at the
school
back in my days there's a headache
there's only 12
there's only 12 of them and they were
soaked and scoped
mouthwash and i would take them out
that's disgusting
that's the way they did that [ __ ] on the
tip
i would deep throat that flute dog yeah
that's how you sanitize back in the day
yeah yeah
it was delicious yes yes that is
our school you think they had enough
money to just everybody had their own
aurora public schools there was 12
flutes there was about
13 kids one person yeah we all shared it
was sharing they know we were about
coronavia
okay y'all didn't take it home in the
suitcase like a lot of people [ __ ] them
no that [ __ ] stayed at the school we
took it home if it was taken home it
ain't coming back
no hell no missing break yeah you left
at the school and you dip it in school
dividend dip it in that [ __ ]
oh this one's for you it's all dripping
wet uh-huh
and you'd blow it and the mouthwash
would come out
that it was so unsanitary i think it was
fantastic it could have caught something
it was she was different back in the day
yeah it was much better
yeah much better how about that when i
get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son